this video is made possible by blinkist
the first hundred people to go to
blinkist.com forward slash visualpolitik
you're going to get unlimited access for
one week to try it out you'll also get
25 percent off if you want the full
membership more about that later but for
now let's get on with it shall we
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dubai is a very different place from any
other place in the persian gulf its
economy isn't based on oil on natural
gas or any other raw material but
instead mainly on tourism transport
trade and finance but despite not being
rich in natural resources in the last
four decades dubai became one of the
most prosperous cities in history
[Music]
since the first towers began to emerge
in the desert this city's growth has
been non-stop the tallest building in
the world the largest shopping mall the
largest airport the most luxurious hotel
you can find everything here and we
could say that this city is made by and
for money everything absolutely
everything in this enclave is shaped by
the money flowing into and out of it
however 2018 hasn't exactly been the
emirates happiest year
[Music]
in the last 12 months the dubai stock
market has plummeted by almost
25 new business licenses have decreased
and for the first time ever employment
has also fallen look we have to we have
to plan for the worst
today more and more analysts are
wondering whether dubai is about to
undergo a huge crisis
and this precisely is the main question
today and that is dubai losing its shine
well listen up
signs and shadows
while much of the arab world is facing a
great deal of chaos economic crises
political crises violence dubai is very
busy developing 3d printers theme parks
air taxi services and even working to
send a probe to mars within just three
years
but as i was saying 2018 hasn't been a
very good year look even though more
than 90 percent of dubai's population is
foreign schools for expatriates are
closing or losing students and moving
companies are showing one clear trend
more people are leaving than arriving
and although the construction pace is
still in full swing it's becoming
increasingly clear that many of these
new buildings are half empty
[Music]
apartments offices hotels shopping
centers obtaining official statistics is
not easy but what happens when there's
more supply than there is demand well
prices drop and that's exactly what is
happening
[Music]
and not only that imar properties stocks
the company that built the burj khalifa
and those of lots of other large
developers listed on the dubai stock
exchange have suffered a collapse of
almost 40 per cent in the last year
alone
want more well dxb entertainment's the
company that owns most of the theme
parks that have opened in dubai in
recent years such as legoland dubai
motiongate and bollywood park is
negotiating with banks to restructure
more than 1 billion in debt simply
because the number of visitors is much
lower than expected
so you can probably see now that it's
not exactly time to celebrate and so the
question we can now ask ourselves here
on visualpolitik is well what the
is happening we're going to ask why is
dubai facing this possible crisis and is
this the end of the emirate that has
broken every middle eastern mold well
let's see
[Music]
the storm
dubai is facing a completely new
scenario in this case the origin of the
problem may lie far beyond its ruler's
competence
allow me to explain dubai is perhaps the
most famous emirate in the united arab
emirates but it's abu dhabi that has the
oil the money and the power in fact even
though sheikh muhammad bin rashid
governs dubai it's this man here
muhammad bin zayed the crown prince of
abu dhabi who de facto rules all the
united arab emirates
well the key to dubai's huge success was
becoming something like the switzerland
of the middle east the freest space the
most legally secure and the most open to
the rest of the planet and of course yes
they absolutely had low taxes however
now some of these things are starting to
be questioned
in the last two to three years the
united arab emirates government has
adopted a very active foreign policy
prince muhammad bin zayed has completely
aligned himself with saudi prince
muhammad bin salman specifically on two
fronts qatar and iran check this out
on the one hand both countries have led
the blockade against qatar a country
that has very close ties with dubai in
fact many international companies
settled in dubai and their executives
traveled to and from doha and jebe
dubai's great port was also qatar's most
important supply center
now well that's all over with the
blockade the uae ordered all qatari
citizens to leave the country most
flights were suspended and freight
traffic was interrupted now qatar is
directly provisioned by or through amman
but no longer through jabel ali
[Music]
with the blockade dubai has lost a very
important commercial partner in addition
to all of this many companies and
investors have noticed that legal
security and maneuverability weren't as
strong as they previously thought
because as you can see dubai ultimately
depends on decisions made in abu dhabi
but that's not all
[Music]
dubai also has very important relations
with iran in fact thanks to its
proximity dubai became something of an
escape route a place for many iranian
leaders and entrepreneurs to stay for a
few days have some fun and spend some
money and not only that every year their
commercial business transactions with
iran surpassed 20 billion but now
because of u.s sanctions and the growing
diplomatic conflict between riyad and
tehran this trade is shrinking by leaps
and bounds the ships that used to send
goods every week now go once a month
in other words in just over a year dubai
has lost two of its largest trading
partners due to decisions made in abu
dhabi and do you think that's all well
it's absolutely not
as dubai became sort of a playground and
second safe zone for iranians the same
thing happened with saudi citizens and
businessmen of course given all the
restrictions that saudi arabia has for
the saudis dubai is an oasis of freedom
and safety well when the saudi prince
mohammed bin salman unleashed his war
against corruption or a move to
consolidate his power rather and locked
up or kidnapped dozens of saudi
businessmen and senior officials the
arab emirates central bank demanded all
banks operating in the country to give
riyadh all the information they had on
the detainees accounts and they
delivered all this information even when
they hadn't been charged information of
course riad used to get the money from
all those businessmen who then had to
buy their freedom with their checkbooks
that way the saudi businessman who
thought that dubai was the true
switzerland of the middle east realized
that this wasn't really the case yes in
dubai there's legal security and your
savings are safe but not the information
with which the autocratic saudi
government can extort you
[Music]
so you're probably beginning to see
where the problem is well due to these
reasons and others the dubai financial
industry is also suffering but oh no we
haven't yet reached the end of this list
the headaches they don't simply stop
here
[Music]
the dropping oil prices in recent years
have affected the purchasing power of
many of the people who spend their money
in dubai a lower oil price means less
income and that as we've seen her in
visualpolitik has meant that some
countries like saudi arabia have to make
many many cuts
and finally there's another factor that
depends on dubai itself in a certain way
the city runs the risk of becoming a
victim of its own success and yes you
heard that right
[Music]
thanks to dubai's huge success its
prices have skyrocketed especially when
it comes to real estate and yeah dubai
does have very low taxes but the state
gets many resources through building
licenses which hasn't helped either if
to all of this we add the fact that many
middle eastern countries to reduce their
dependence on oil have launched plans to
copy this city by giving many advantages
to their investors the result is that
dubai has lost its appeal to
international companies in recent years
anyway as you now see these are the
roots of the problem abu dhabi qatar
iran and the cost of its own success
they've all decreased this emirate
city's attractive oasis status but what
many of you might be wondering is well
what now so listen up
[Music]
perspectives
[Music]
even though its economy is expected to
grow by just over two percent in 2019 as
you can see dubai isn't going through
the best of times but hold on a second
because this doesn't mean everything's
lost not at all
in spite of everything this city emirate
continues to be an oasis in the desert
and its government seems to have a clear
idea of the keys to its success
therefore what sheikh muhammad bin
rashid's government is doing now is
trying to make dubai's economy even more
competitive with its neighbors to do so
they're making it easier to obtain a
visa they're ensuring that expatriates
who lose their jobs have an easier time
staying and they're decreasing the
obstacles of foreign business owners
outside of the special economic zones
in other words they want to connect
dubai even more with the rest of the
world in fact local authorities have
high hopes for the arrival of chinese
investors
this is a market cycle that we have to
accept the government is doing what it
did in past slumps sitting down with
business to figure out solutions fahad
al-gargawi head of the investment agency
dubai fbi
when the upturn does arrive dubai's
companies will emerge leaner and more
competitive katija hak head of regional
research at local lender emirates nbd
folks this is what is happening in this
city-state that has had such a positive
impact on the middle east yes in dubai a
lot of unfortunate things may be
reported but opening up to the world has
been a breath of fresh air for one of
the most hostile areas on the planet in
terms of human rights in dubai not only
can you drink alcohol eat pork and pray
at a catholic church now you can even go
to a synagogue and eat kosher food yeah
again you really did hear that right
as the gulf warms up to israel a
synagogue grows in dubai anyway only the
future will be able to tell if this
city-state's frenetic growth pace will
continue or if instead dubai is doomed
to suffer a huge crisis and lose its
shine so far the party continues
a dubai company will build the largest
sports shopping center in the world so i
hope you enjoyed that video and as i
said at the beginning this one was made
possible by blinkist now do you manage
to read all the books you want you
manage to get all of that knowledge in
your head probably not right i mean
everyone seems busier than ever it seems
like there's hardly time to spend
learning it's much easier just to click
on that other tempting video over there
on the right about some nonsense or
other now you might not think that you
have a ton of time to read but the good
news is that even if you don't you can
use blinkist blinkist is an app that
takes the best insights and need to know
information from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15 minutes which you can either
read or listen to they've got a huge
library and 8 million users
i think i'm actually probably the ideal
blinkist customer i spend a lot of time
working and far less time learning than
i should and i often plug into the audio
versions and listen to them while i'm
like unloading the dishwasher and boring
tasks like that listen they've got tons
of popular titles like the four hour
work week from tim ferriss but they've
also got stuff you guys probably really
be into lots of political stuff and you
know like i often say on this channel
let's take a look back at the history
they've got books condensed like the
silk roads by peter frankipan the first
hundred people to go to blinkist.com
forward slash visualpolitik are going to
get unlimited access for one week to try
it out you'll also get 25 off if you
want the full membership move fast grab
one of those now and get started in one
of those political history books the
seven day trial is completely free you
can cancel it at any time during that
trial if you're not into it but you will
be and as always thank you for watching
[Music]
you